we think of compassion we often think
that well I'm either a compassionate
person or I'm not so-and-so is
compassionate or not the truth is that
research shows that we all have
compassion and that being kind is
actually our first response
it's our first automatic tendency so
when you give people only a few seconds
to make a decision about whether they'll
be fair or not whether they'll share or
not whether it'll be kind or not their
very first impulse is to do it if you
give them a little bit more time to
think about it maybe they'll choose a
more selfish option but there are a
number of reasons for that as well in
many ways we live in a society where
there's the norm of self-interest we
believe that we're all self-interested
so sometimes people hold themselves back
from doing an act of kindness because
they're worried that people will think
they're self-interested that they're
doing it because they want to get
something so what I'm trying to get at
is that we all are built to be kind to
be compassionate there's this idea out
there of survival of the fittest and we
attribute that to Darwin that was false
it's attributed to Herbert Benson who
was trying to justify racial hierarchies
Darwin's message was much more akin to
the idea that's simply called sympathy
or what we can call compassion is the
reason that we're alive today we're such
a vulnerable species you look at how
we're built our skin is so thin if we
didn't have each other to support each
other through through the dangers of
life and so forth if our ancestors
didn't stick together and help each
other there is no way we would have
survived so he actually pointed more to
the fact that compassion was essential
to our survival so compassion is innate
first of all but secondly it can be
strengthened so if you feel like you
would like to nurture that more in your
life you can do so through practices
like meditation but also through
actively deciding that you want to every
day be as kind as you can to the people
around you
you